[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement hebdo pour décrypter ensemble
l'actualité de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Sénat avec vous Cathy Gilder bonjour
Alexandre et cette semaine nous
accueillons mode Gatel notre invité
bonjour bonjour vous êtes députés de
Paris on vous a vu récemment à côté de
François Bayrou pour les universités
d'été du MoDem vous êtes secrétaire
général du MoDem on va voir avec vous le
feuilleton de la semaine et elle a une
cette semaine la réforme des retraites
il y aura bien une concertation de
plusieurs mois qui doit aboutir à un
projet de loi adopter à d'ici la fin de
l'hiver mais attention Emmanuel Macron
prévient en cas de blocage des
oppositions il menace de dissoudre
l'Assemblée nationale
le début de l'examen du budget à 2023 au
Parlement le ministre de l'économie et
des finances Bruno Le Maire défend un
texte qui je cite protège le pouvoir
d'achat des Français
et puis le rapport choc de la délégation
au droit des femmes du Cénac qui dénonce
les violences sexuelles dans l'industrie
de la pornographie
[Musique]
avec cette question à la Une la réforme
des retraites aura-t-elle lieu pas de
passage en force du mois pas pour
l'instant mais un projet de loi est
annoncé pour l'hiver avec le risque pour
le gouvernement d'une motion de censure
des oppositions dans ce cas Emmanuel
Macron n'exclut pas de dissoudre
l'Assemblée nationale c'est le
feuilleton de la semaine signé Stéphanie
Despierres Emmanuel Macron temporise sur
la méthode et sur le calendrier jeudi la
première ministre a annoncé qu'il n'y
aurait pas de réforme des retraites dès
cet automne
on fait le choix du dialogue et de la
concertation son allié le modem de
François Bayrou était vent debout contre
l'idée d'une réforme des retraites par
amendements dont le budget de la
Sécurité sociale même chose pour la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale mais
la réforme aura bien lieu d'ici l'été
prochain Emmanuel Macron il tient c'est
sa promesse de campagne alors Elisabeth
borne a précisé le calendrier un projet
de loi sera adopté avant la fin de
l'hiver les discussions avec les
partenaires sociaux et les partis vont
donc continuer jusqu'en décembre pour le
moment la nuit Pesse et le RN campe sur
leur position au moment où il y a des
profits records dans notre pays et un
record de malheur aussi pour tant de
gens et des millions de gens dans notre
pays il est plus que temps d'augmenter
les salaires plutôt que l'âge de la
retraite et je pense que si Emmanuel
Macron ne redevient pas raisonnable il
le comprendra dans la douleur que ça
soit dans la rue dans l'hémicycle ou
dans les urnes la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est est-ce que on est prêt à
sacrifier chaque année en trouvant des
sources économies de bons sans dont on
parler 10 milliards d'euros pour faire
en sorte que les Français puissent
partir à la retraite dignement sans
avoir le dos cassé sans avoir les bras
cassés et nous nous défendons vous le
savez un départ à la retraite à 60 ans
et 40 annuités pour tous ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 17 et 20 ans
si jamais l'opposition parvient à voter
une motion de censure Emmanuel Macron
est très clair il y aura 10 solutions un
avertissement notamment pour les
républicains groupe charnière et en
théorie favorable à la réforme
mood Gatel alors là c'est le scénario
qu'on a essayé d'imaginer pour l'instant
on n'y est pas parce que ce projet de
loi n'est pas encore déposé mais si
jamais il y avait un projet de loi et
une motion de censure qu'on se trouve ce
projet de loi et ce qui est manuel
Macron a raison de brandir cette arme
politique d'une dissolution c'est quand
même pas rien oui mais la réforme des
retraites c'est pas rien non plus la
réforme des retraites c'est finalement
un des piliers le fondement de notre
pacte social et moi je défends l'idée
qu'il faut réformer cette cette
politique aujourd'hui pour deux raisons
la première raison c'est la pérennité du
système aujourd'hui on le on le sait le
système est en déficit il ne l'est pas
cette année mais il le sera partir de
l'année prochaine et jusqu'à 2035 voire
2050 en fonction des prévisions
budgétaires
or c'est la base de cette solidarité
générationnelle dont on bénéficie depuis
quasi un siècle et donc il est important
de pérenniser ce système parce que c'est
un système de solidarité et puis un
autre volet auquel nous sommes au modem
extrêmement attaché c'est faire en sorte
que ce régime soit plus juste or
aujourd'hui il ne l'est pas on va parler
de cette réforme des retraites sur le
fond mais d'abord une réaction quand
même sur cette menace de dissolution de
l'Assemblée nationale de la part des
manuel Macron c'est quoi c'est un coup
de bluff l'idée c'est de faire peur aux
oppositions non je pense que c'est à
chacun de prendre ses responsabilités
est-ce qu'on a besoin d'une réforme des
retraites il y a beaucoup de il y a
beaucoup de parties qui répondent oui
d'ailleurs je rappelle que le régime
sous lequel nous sommes actuellement
c'est la loi Touraine donc réaliser sous
le gouvernement Hollande et on sait que
chaque année les sénateurs et les
députés les républicains déposent des
amendements visant à allonger la durée
de la la du temps de cotisation donc que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités pour
faire en sorte qu'on réformes le système
des retraites de la manière la plus
juste possible alors il y avait une voix
qui semblait se dessiner une réforme par
le biais d'un amendement au projet de
loi de financement la sécurité sociale
dès maintenant en réalité cela a suscité
les foutes des oppositions notamment de
François Bayrou qui a visiblement
longuement discuté avec Emmanuel Macron
et finalement Emmanuel Macron a reculé
puisque il n'y aura pas de réforme par
voie d'amendement c'est une victoire
pour François Barot écoutez moi ce qui
me choque ce soir une victoire de
l'intérêt général pour que cette réforme
est là il y a son terme parce que
finalement ce que ce que souhaitait
François Bayrou c'était qu'on puisse
rassembler mettre tout le monde autour
de la table sur le constat première
victoire pour lui puisqu'il n'y aura pas
de passage en force tout de suite on a
besoin sur cette réforme qui n'est pas
qu'une simple réforme financière le
sujet c'est pas simplement équilibrer
les comptes le sujet c'est quelle
société on veut par rapport au sujet du
travail et au sujet de la retraite et
pour ce faire on a besoin de mettre tout
le monde autour de la table les
représentants des partenaires sociaux
les partis politiques pour partager un
constat en dissertation c'est à dire pas
de quoi faire on a le temps on a le
temps de de faire en sorte que les
conditions de la concertation soient
réunies et après on aura un texte parce
que ce qu'il faut bien avoir en tête
c'est que cette réforme elle est
nécessaire moi je la défends mais c'est
une réforme à la fois de société pour
une société plus juste donc finalement
François Bayrou a eu raison de défendre
cette concertation et de mettre son
mécontentement sur la place publique il
n'était pas le seul à demander que
visiblement
c'est pas la question qui a gagné la
question c'est est-ce qu'on arrivera à
avoir les meilleures conditions
possibles pour faire cette réforme que
j'estime nécessaire alors sur le fond
dans cette concertation plusieurs sujets
vont être discutés la pénibilité elle
est carrière longue mais le report
progressif de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans 2027 puis à 65 ans en
2031 ça et bien c'est non négociable
selon chef de l'État vous êtes d'accord
écoutez moi je pense qu'il faut mettre
tous les sujets sur la table le sujet y
compris l'agilité carrière longue régime
spéciaux
hétérogénéité la situation notamment je
pense au sujet de la discrimination
faite aux femmes il n'y a aucun arrière
arraché ce sont tous ces sujets qu'il
faut qu'on mette sur la table régime
spéciaux également et bien évidemment je
pense que nos concitoyens comprennent
que dans la mesure où l'espérance de vie
augmente il n'est pas illogique qu'on
travaille un petit peu plus d'ailleurs
la réforme Touraine a enclenché cette
démarche avec des trimestres
supplémentaires chaque année pour pour
les personnes qui accélère la durée de
quotidienne qui accélère le temps de
cotisation et l'âge de départ à la
retraite donc je pense que nos
concitoyens peuvent tout à fait le
comprendre simplement simplement on
n'arrive pas à l'âge du départ à la
retraite de la même manière quand on a
eu un travail pénible ou non et cette
dimension là pour moi elle est
absolument prioritaire et il faut
vraiment qu'on mette ce sujet sur la
table alors elle avait déjà été portée
cette réforme de retraite en 2020 mais
il y a eu l'épidémie de covid qu'il a
suspendu est-ce que qu'est-ce qui dit
que demain si c'est présenté au
Parlement il n'y aura pas une crise
grave qui va balayer à nouveau la
réforme c'est possible ça aussi vous
avez tout à fait raison de le rappeler
on avait avancé sur un certain nombre de
sujets et notamment sur les carrières
archives sur la pénibilité lors de la
discussion près prépondément donc il
faut qu'on reparte aussi de ce qui a été
fait à ce moment-là et je pense vraiment
qu'il y a une vraie volonté partagée
d'avancer sur cette question bien
évidemment les Français le comprendront
ils sont prêts malgré leurs difficultés
de pouvoir d'achat ils sont prêts à une
réforme de la retraite à reculer l'âge
de leur départ là écoutez moi je fais
partie d'une génération qui me dit que
sans réforme des retraites je n'aurais
pas de retraite et je considère que
c'est un sujet que c'est un sujet
vraiment de société qu'il faut qu'on
mette tous les toutes les questions sur
la table la question de la pénibilité on
est une la question des carrières
archers en est une autre il faut
vraiment qu'on arrive à trouver un
consensus sur à quel moment on part en
retraite en fonction de l'hétérogénéité
des situations et puis il faut qu'on
travaille aussi sur le travail des
seniors parce que on sait aussi qu'en
France on est moins bon que la moyenne
européenne sur le taux d'emploi des
seniors et sur cette question aussi tout
le monde doit prendre sa part et en
premier lieu les entreprises parce que
reculer l'âge du départ à la retraite si
c'est pour que le chômage partiel soit
la règle pour les 60-65 ans n'a pas de
sens alors vous aurez beaucoup de
travail en perspective puisqu'il y a
déjà un rendez-vous incontournable de
cet automne c'est l'examen du budget au
Parlement Bruno Le Maire a présenté le
texte au député au sénateur ce budget
2023 a-t-il dit Marc la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte mais le ministre a
défendu un budget protecteur écoutez
Bruno Le Maire ainsi que ce qu'a répondu
cette semaine Pierre Moscovici
ce n'est pas un budget de rigueur
ce n'est pas un budget de facilité
c'est un budget responsable et
protecteur dans des temps de grande
incertitude
et c'est un budget qui veut tenir le
juste équilibre entre la protection
nécessaire de nos compatriotes et le
rétablissement indispensable les
finances publiques concernant le
scénario macroéconomique du gouvernement
le Haut Conseil considère que le taux de
croissance retenu pour 2023 paraît un
peu élevé en revanche nous estimons que
les prévisions d'inflation à 4,2% de
masse salariale dans les branches
marchandes à 5% sont quant à elle
plausibles alors à peine présenté un
mode Gatel ce budget a fait l'objet de
critiques de pas et d'autres de toutes
les oppositions qui ont dit tout le mal
qu'elle pensait de ce budget et vous au
modem vous dites quoi vous dites tout le
bien que vous pensez de ce budget vous
applaudissez Bruno Le Maire pour la
présentation de ce projet de loi de
finance 2023
ce projet de loi de finances il a quatre
objectifs d'abord continuer à protéger
les Français et ce projet de loi de
finances mais en oeuvre tout ce que nous
avons voté cet été c'est-à-dire
l'augmentation du point d'indice la
poursuite du bouclier tarifaire le
bouclier est tarifaire c'est 50
milliards dans le projet de loi de
finance 2023 c'est considérable et il
faut qu'on continue à protéger les
Français et c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'inflation et en France la
plus faible de la zone euro donc la
protection des Français
premier objectif deuxième objectif c'est
préparer l'avenir notamment sur la
question du regalien c'est
l'augmentation du budget de la défense
des forces armées c'est plus 1,3
milliards pour nos forces ne forcent de
sécurité sur le terrain donc évidemment
ça va dans le bon sens il y a la
question de l'éducation et notamment la
revalorisation des salaires on le sait
il faut qu'on continue à travailler sur
cette question les enseignants ne sont
pas suffisamment payés et puis il y a le
retour sur une trajectoire
vers une un retour à 3% de déficit à
horizon 2027 parce qu'on a besoin de
débloquer des marges de manoeuvre en cas
de besoin et bien justement sur ce sujet
à la droite estime que ce budget n'est
pas assez ambitieux en terme d'économie
il faudrait réduire davantage les
dépenses compte tenues notamment du
contexte économique et du risque
d'inflation est-ce que ce budget est
assez raisonnable alors il est
raisonnable et puis j'écoutais Pierre
Moscovici dire que les que les
prévisions étaient
peut-être un petit peu ambitieuse moi
j'ai vu aussi les prévisions de l'OCDE
et du FMI qui partent qui table sur des
prévisions de croissance supérieures à
ce que le gouvernement a établi dans son
projet de loi de finances donc me
semble-t-il on est sur sur une sur un
étiage assez juste en matière de
croissance et en matière d'inflation
alors après nos amis républicains certes
ils veulent que nous baissions la
dépense publique mais moi quand je les
entends dans narcissiques ils sont en
permanence en train de demander des
dépenses supplémentaires donc j'aimerais
savoir où ils souhaitent faire faire ses
économies et puis on est sur un sur un
déficit de 5% c'était aussi le déficit
prévu pour l'année 2022 la guerre en
Ukraine est passée par là et je trouve
que cette étage est relativement juste
alors si le gouvernement n'a pas la
majorité pour faire voter ce budget et
bien il pourrait cette fois utiliser
l'arme du 49 3 l'article 49.3 de la
Constitution qui permet de faire passer
un texte sans vote ce serait de nouveau
un passage en force est-ce que pour vous
c'est une bonne idée ou pas de menacer
dès maintenant du recours à 49-3 alors
il y a le sujet du 49-3 il y a le sujet
de la méthode et je voudrais saluer le
travail qui a été fait notamment par
Gabriel Attal autour des dialogues de
Bercy de mettre autour de la table
l'ensemble des représentants des
formations politiques pour travailler
très en amont sur la question du budget
et d'ailleurs ça a été salué par un
certain nombre de représentants parce
que ce qui compte c'est qu'on mette
l'ensemble des propositions sur la table
et qu'on aille le plus loin possible
bien évidemment si un moment il y a
blocage il faudra en tirer toutes les
toutes les conséquences le 49-3 c'est un
outil au service du gouvernement et bien
évidemment s'il l'utilise ça n'est pas
un passage en force de mon point de vue
alors il y a une autre question qui se
pose sur ce budget c'est son ambition
écologique qu'on a vu tous les signes du
réchauffement climatique notamment sur
notre territoire cet été Bruno Le Maire
le reconnaît ce budget n'est pas assez
vert et ça fait partie des critiques de
la gauche vous aussi vous trouvez qu'il
y a un manque d'ambition écologique du
gouvernement avec ce budget alors moi je
salue deux choses c'est la mise en place
du fond vert pour les collectivités
territoriales 1,5 milliards d'euros ce
qui n'est pas rien et puis
l'augmentation de ma prime rénov le
budget dédié à l'amélioration enfin
l'accélération des rénovations
thermiques puisqu'on sait que le bâti
fait partie des premières sources de
démission de gaz à effet de serre et
puis il y a le plan vélo dont je me
réjouis aussi parce que je pense que il
faut qu'on
accélère sur sur ce sujet donc oui il
faut aller plus vite plus fort sur la
question de la transition écologique
mais moi je salue de véritables avancées
dans ce budget donc si on vous écoute
quand tu arriveras Noël et qu'il faudra
voter l'ensemble de ce budget avec 49-3
ou pas la majorité pour raconter sur le
modèle tous les députés de modem pour
voter d'une seule voix ce budget écoutez
c'est nous on va continuer à travailler
on a un certain nombre de propositions à
faire j'espère qu'elles seront qu'elles
seront entendues par le gouvernement
mais bien évidemment on sera en soutien
à ce à ce budget qui a été présenté
comme un budget de un projet de loi de
finance de protection des Français et
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
l'orientation qui est prise par par ce
projet de loi de finances n'oublions pas
qu'on est quand même dans une situation
extrêmement difficile pour beaucoup
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qu'il faut
continuer à avoir des aides ciblées pour
les plus fragiles et je pense notamment
au bouclier tarifaire et au chèque
énergie un mode Gatel on va maintenant
parler d'un rapport qui a fait beaucoup
de bruit cette semaine un rapport
sénatorial de la
au droit des femmes du Sénat sur
l'industrie de la pornographie après six
mois d'enquête d'audition de déplacement
sur le terrain et bien les sénateurs et
sénatrices dénoncent les violences
sexuelles qui sont commises dans ce
milieu et puis les dangers que
représente les sites pornographiques
pour nos enfants Jérémy Hansmann
six mois de travaux des dizaines
d'heures d'auditions et un rapport
alarmant la délégation au droit des
femmes du Sénat dresse un tableau très
sombre de l'industrie du porno gangrené
selon les sénatrices par une violence
systémique envers les femmes l'industrie
pornographique aujourd'hui elle est
indissociable des violences 90% des
scènes qui sont montrées sont des scènes
de violence non simulées chantage
emprise acte sexuels forcés violent de
soumission le rapport dénonce des
conditions de tournage déplorables et
des méthodes de recrutement ciblant des
femmes précaires et fragiles
la culture du viol c'est soumettre les
femmes et ça s'apparente énormément à ce
qu'on voit au niveau de la prostitution
des pratiques devenues des normes et
diffusées aujourd'hui massivement via
les plateformes réseaux sociaux ou
messagerie privée chaque mois en France
19 millions de personnes visitent un
site pornographique pour les sénatrices
il y a donc urgence elle propose 23
recommandations pour imposer la lutte
contre les violences pornographiques
dans le débat public faciliter les
suppressions de contenu illicites et le
droit à l'oubli et protéger les mineurs
en appliquant la loi sur l'interdiction
d'accès parmi les mesures évoquées la
création d'un délit d'incitation à la
violence sexuelle qui pourrait
sanctionner les plateformes de diffusion
nous voulons que ce délit d'incitation à
la haine sexiste à la violence sexuelle
figure également dans le code pénal et
plus s'appliquer à des vidéos qui
montrent le viol l'humiliation les
violences sexuelles comme étant la norme
de la sexualité un rapport destiné aussi
à alerter les pouvoirs publics et
constitués selon les sénatrices une base
pour un futur texte de loi un mot de
Gatel qu'est-ce que vous inspire ce
rapport de vos collectionnatrices
d'abord je voudrais saluer leur travail
parce que c'était un travail
assez inédit
et et rassemblant finalement l'ensemble
de l'équipe politique autour de constat
absolument édifiant
sordide qui s'inscrivent aussi dans un
contexte judiciaire particulièrement
sordide pour moi il y a plusieurs choses
il y a la question il y a la question de
la protection des enfants à travers la
restriction d'accès qui est absolument
indispensable
un chiffre
première image pornographique vu par les
enfants c'est à l'âge de 9 ans 9 ans
compte tenu de l'image qui est véhiculée
des femmes dans ces dans cette
pornographie évidemment ça ne ça ne
laisse personne indemne et il faut tout
faire pour que les lois que nous avons
votées en 2020 et en 2022 puissent enfin
s'appliquer c'est-à-dire l'interdiction
strict de la pornographie pour les
mineurs et puis sur le sur l'aspect
l'aspect de l'image des femmes
véhiculées on est là quand même sur des
questions d'exploitation sexuelle de
traîtres de traite d'être humain
absolument épouvantable et il faut
évidemment renforcer les devoirs et les
obligations des plateformes parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils s'affranchissent en
disant nous ne sommes que des diffuseurs
ça c'est absolument inacceptable
l'industrie l'industrie pornographique
et
gangrené par des pratiques ignobles et
il faut évidemment qu'on agisse vous ça
veut dire que c'est un peu une zone de
non-droit qui faut réglementer est-ce
qu'il faut créer dans le code pénal un
nouveau délit d'incitation aux violences
sexuelles telles qu'on les a vu énumérés
dans dans le sujet alors à titre
personnel moi j'y suis favorable et je
suis favorable aussi parce qu'on
revienne sur la question éditeur
diffuseurs des plateformes c'est trop
facile de de faire de l'argent puisqu'on
parle quand même de milliards d'euros
lié à l'industrie pornographique au
niveau mondial souhaitant de jeunes
femmes en exploitant des jeunes femmes
et en disant je ne suis pas au courant
des conditions de tournage moi j'ai une
charte de déontologie si elle est pas si
si elle n'est pas respectée c'est pas
mon problème si c'est mon problème parce
qu'à partir du moment où je suis
diffuseur alors cette question des
plateformes elle n'est pas seulement
pour la question de la pornographie mais
il faut vraiment qu'on avance sur ce
sujet l'Union européenne a beaucoup
avancé sur la sur cette question il faut
désormais qu'on aille plus loin
notamment sur la question de la
pornographie c'est ça c'est un problème
international est-ce que nous en France
on a les moyens de combattre ces grandes
plateformes pornographiques qui sont des
multinationales je pense qu'on a les
moyens
l'interdiction de la diffusion à des
mineurs de moins de 18 ans
charge à nous de la faire respecter il y
a des il y a des il y a des logiciels
qui existent il y a des moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas de savoir comment est-ce
que les plateformes s'y prennent
simplement je ne veux plus que les
mineurs puissent avoir accès à ces
images vous imaginez le traumatisme pour
ces pour ses enfants quand ils sont
exposés à ce genre d'images de 9 ans dès
l'âge de 9 ans moins de 15 ans c'est
deux tiers des enfants qui ont vu des
films ou des extraits de films
pornographiques
évidemment ça construit une relation à
l'autre une relation à la femme
notamment qui n'est absolument pas celle
à laquelle la société doit aspirer donc
il faut qu'on agisse et qu'on agisse
fort et vraiment je voudrais saluer le
travail qui a été fait par ces quatre
sénatrices
on va juste une petite dernière question
est-ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à
l'interdiction de la pornographie alors
ce n'est pas ce que demande ce rapport
mais ce qu'il faut l'encadrer davantage
cette production pornographique voir
l'interdire alors interdiction pour les
mineurs c'est sûr encadrement strict
quand on quand on voit ce chiffre 19
millions de Français qui une fois par
mois se rendent sur des sur des
plateformes l'interdiction est un peu
illusoire en revanche l'encadrement
extrêmement strict est indispensable
allez on va passer à l'agenda de la
semaine prochaine à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord à l'Assemblée nationale lundi
marquera l'ouverture de la session
ordinaire après la pause d'été s'ouvrira
avec un débat sur l'Ukraine sans vote et
sur les conséquences de la guerre pour
la France et puis mardi le rendez-vous
incontournable au grand moment de la vie
parlementaire le retour des questions au
gouvernement et puis au Sénat pour
l'ouverture de cette session ordinaire
et bien des débats seront organisés sur
l'état critique de certains services
publics et notamment celui de la justice
et des urgences hospitalières et puis
mercredi le Sénat examinera en
commission la proposition de loi de la
sénatrice centriste Valérie léthard qui
propose de créer une aide universelle
d'urgence aux victimes de violences
conjugales et maux de Gatel ont souhaité
vous interroger justement sur cette
proposition de loi alors pour bien
comprendre cette aide universelle
d'urgence pour les victimes de violences
conjugales prendre la forme d'un prêt à
taux zéro débloquer en 48 heures par la
Caisse d'Allocations familiale d'un
montant équivalent au RSA et verser
pendant trois mois le but c'est que les
femmes victimes qui décident de quitter
leur domicile ne se retrouvent pas en
difficulté financière a priori vous si
vous étiez sénatrice votre Gatel vous la
voteriez cette proposition de loi
ecoutez je la voterai parce que les
femmes qui sont confrontées à des
situations de violence on devait une
montagne de défi à relever d'abord c'est
de partir partir de leur appartement
parce que bien souvent c'est à elle de
partir malheureusement alors il y a
beaucoup de choses ont été faites
notamment en matière de d'hébergement
d'urgence à destination des femmes
victimes de violences et de leurs
enfants simplement c'est toujours
insuffisant et effectivement elles sont
confrontées lorsque elles ont pris la
décision mais elles sont confrontées à
des à des à des difficultés matérielles
et donc ce cette possibilité justement
de pouvoir compter sur un prêt à taux
zéro va tout à fait dans le bon sens par
rapport aux enjeux qui sont les leurs
une question sur les violences
conjugales de la part de certains
responsables politiques on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment notamment
de la nupes l'alliance des gauches mode
Gatel est-ce que vous diriez je cite
qu'une gifle n'est pas égale au fait de
battre sa femme tous les jours c'est ce
qui a fermé manuel Bompard l'un des
dirigeants de la France insoumise dans
l'affaire Adria catenens qui a été mis
en retrait à qui s'est mis en retrait
après avoir reconnu avoir giflé sa femme
on a assisté ces derniers jours à
des propos à des réactions de la part de
deux parties notamment
profondément choquant
le pouvoir politique est pas exemple de
violence sexiste et sexuelle
comme d'autres milieux mais je pense que
le milieu politique
particulièrement par exemple simplement
la manière dont ont été gérées
pour moi est un fiasco total que ce soit
chez LFI ou chez les Verts et il me
semble que
on doit agir et que les partis
politiques ont plusieurs responsabilités
d'abord c'est la prévention bon
évidemment prévenir les violences
sexuelles et sexistes en leur sein c'est
l'accompagnement des victimes les
accompagner pour porter plainte et puis
c'est l'alerte mais moi je ne souhaite
pas que les partis politiques se
substituent à la justice pour autant il
faut pas non plus considérer qu'il ne se
passe rien et que le milieu politique
est totalement exempt de violence donc
il doit être exemplaire pour vous
il doit être exemplaire il doit mettre
tous les garde-fous il doit mieux
sensibiliser les responsables politiques
mais ne pas se substituer à la justice
et ne pas tomber dans le fiasco auquel
on a assisté ces derniers jours
mais c'est la fin de cette émission
merci beaucoup mode Gatel d'y avoir
participé et merci à tous de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour ne rien rater les
incontournables du Parlement Ciao
[Musique]